how's it going everybody welcome back to
the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it's been a while but we do have
some Spider-Man 4 news today some pretty
big news it looks like Spider-Man 4 5
and 6 the next Trilogy for Tom Holland
yes he is returning and it looks like
we're about to get some pretty huge
announcements from Sony in regards to
these films so not only are we going to
be talking about Spider-Man 4 today but
of course we have to talk about Tom
Holland's new contract everything that
we know so far and what we know about
Spider-Man 4 5 and 6. now right away
I'll give you some news about what we've
heard about the release date now a lot
of people know but pretty much the
biggest comic book event of the year is
about to come up in July San Diego
Comic-Con this of course is where we get
Hall h in Marvel Studios usually
announcing all of the really really big
announcements that they have this
typically includes the reveals of their
phases and the movies that are going to
go in their phases now last San Diego
Comic-Con for Marvel study videos at
Hall age they revealed the entirety of
phase five or at least we think they
revealed the entirety of Phase 5 and
they revealed part of phase six only
given us the Fantastic Four Avengers
King Dynasty and Avengers Secret Wars
now later on they would go on to
announce that Deadpool 3 would be a part
of phase six as well so the big
announcements are supposed to come in a
couple of months from now however as we
know Marvel Studios does not typically
handle any announcements for Spider-Man
at least not on film Sony still has the
movie rights to Spider-Man so typically
Sony Pictures have their own panel and
they are the ones who release
information about Spider-Man whether
that's the official release date the
title the trailer the cast really
anything typically comes from Sony but
Sony could have a panel at San Diego
Comic-Con but the good news is according
to some insiders Sony might not actually
wait that long and they might actually
reveal the release date and possibly
even reveal the new name for Spider-Man
4 as well sooner than San Diego
Comic-Con while well since San Diego
Comic-Con is only about two and a half
months away that means within the next
two months we might know the official
release date for Spider-Man and what the
title of the film is actually called now
we might actually know the official
release date for Spider-Man 4 already
earlier today Insider Alex P from the
cosmic circus stated this in reply to a
tweet about Sony announcing everything
at San Diego Comic-Con Alex P said this
possibly but it would be a first because
it's not something that has happened
before unless Sony has a panel at sdcc
I'm waiting for more info but based on
preliminary info I think it might come
sooner than people expect then after
this The Insider account my time to
shine hello who has a very excellent
track record stated August 28
2025. so that date right there August
28th 2025 could be the official release
date for Spider-Man 4. now what's really
interesting about this is that it would
come after Avengers the Kang Dynasty but
based off of everything that we know Tom
Holland's Spider-Man is going to be
pretty much the main character of
Avengers King Dynasty my time to shine
hello stated that he is going to be the
lead of the movie now at first people
kind of got confused about this
statement myself included what she means
is he is going to be the lead character
not the actual leader of the Avengers
team although he still very well could
be the leader that is entirely possible
but Tom Holland is going to be the lead
actor so Spider-Man is going to have a
ton of focus on him in the movie and
this makes sense because right now we
are still kind of establishing a new
Avengers team it hasn't been put
together yet it's supposedly supposed to
start happening in Captain America
Untitled if you haven't heard it looks
like they are no longer calling Captain
America 4 Captain America New World
Order it's Untitled right now if we hear
anything else about that I'll be sure to
do an update so right now it looks like
Tom Holland is going to be the lead of
Kang Dynasty we're going to see a lot of
Spider-Man then then from there it's
going to spin off into his fourth
Spider-Man film and here's where it gets
really really interesting we basically
know that Spider-Man 4 5 and 6 are going
to have Kingpin involved some way or
somehow Kingpin is going to be kind of
like a sub-tier big bat of the street
level Avengers team he's going to be the
villain in the Echo series and the
Daredevil series and eventually he is
going to run into Spider-Man the only
question is when now it could be
Spider-Man 4 but something that we heard
a while ago makes us believe that
Spider-Man 4 might actually kind of be
another multiversal film and the reason
is this according to some reports that
we've heard from these insiders the
movies that happen after King Dynasty
and the shows as well are going to be
centered around the Multiverse this is
pretty much when it's all going to break
because by the time we get to Avengers
Secret Wars the Multiverse would have
already had to be broken at that point
in time basically Marvel Studios is
going to use the movies and shows
between the King Dynasty and between
Secret Wars to do a lot of multiple is
traveling so they don't have to shove
everything into Secret Wars which
honestly is a good strategy and they're
also talking about making secret Wars
into a two-part film which honestly
wouldn't be bad either now if this ends
up being true then Kingpin might not
have a very prominent role in Spider-Man
4 they could be saving that for
Spider-Man 5 or 6. if Spider-Man 4 is
going to be another multiversal film for
Spider-Man which would make sense the
last time we saw him in Spider-Man 3 no
way home that was all about breaking the
Multiverse then the next time we'll see
him is in King Dynasty which at the end
of the movie The Universe should be kind
of breaking or at least the Avengers are
going to know that they have to travel
through the Multiverse because they have
to fight King and all of his other
variants so it would make sense that
Spider-Man 4 which would take place
after Kang Dynasty would also be about
the Multiverse so it's possible that we
could get a variant of Kang as the
villain for Spider-Man 4. what we know
about Tom Holland's contract that he
reportedly has already signed is a deal
for three more solo Spider-Man films two
team-up films which course would be
Avengers King Dynasty and Avengers
Secret Wars and then one other project
that we're not sure if it's a movie or a
show yet but it will not be a solo movie
or a solo show it will be a team up
movie or show we're hoping maybe
Daredevil a Spider-Man and Daredevil
team up in the Daredevil Born Again
series but if that doesn't happen
Daredevil can definitely show up in one
of Spider-Man's films in fact what I
think is going to happen after Avengers
Secret Wars and after Spider-Man 4 with
Spider-Man 5 and 6. I think this will be
a build up to fighting Kingpin perhaps
maybe in the sixth movie because keep in
mind Spider-Man no way home and its
post-credits scene did tease the Venom
symbiote now like we've talked about
before I'm really hoping that they
choose to go the comic accurate route
for Spider-Man in getting the Venom
symbiote and he gets it in secret Wars I
think it would be really cool to have
Tom Holland Spider-Man have the Venom
symbiote in secret Wars fighting Kang
this would be awesome and if that does
happen that would mean he would be
dealing with the Venom Sim be out in
Spider-Man 5. so Spider-Man 5 could be
that Venom symbiote film then maybe the
Symbiote gets away goes on to somebody
else and that person maybe it's our
universe's Eddie Brock goes on to team
up with Kingpin and four other members
and they form a true Sinister Six and
that is the movie that we get for
Spider-Man 6. I'm hoping that this is
the case I think Spider-Man 4 5 and 6
would be really cool if done this way
especially with Spider-Man's involvement
in secret Wars in King Dynasty and it
sounds like we are going to get an
official announcement about Spider-Man 4
relatively soon possibly within the next
couple of months according to these
reports but right now it looks like
Spider-Man is coming in August of 2025
after King Dynasty so a little over two
years until our next solo Spider-Man
film but in May of 2025 we're going to
see him appear in King Dynasty so let me
know your thoughts about this in the
comments down below what would you like
to see the plot be for each of these
Spider-Man films let us know down below
also don't forget to like the video
subscribe and leave a comment for chance
to win an Xbox series X A PS5 some
Marvel Legends items or some DC items as
well we pick a winner at the end of each
month and the winner gets to choose also
don't forget to follow us on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching wolf
please